hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game from the legendary 1991
Linares tournament where evasly vanchuka
crushed to the field he crushed everyone
he defeated uh uh I I can't stress this
enough he really defeated everyone he in
one tournament he defeated Garrick as
part of Anatoly karpov and the
vishwanathan Anand so he he he had the
the greatest Tournament of his life and
I've covered this tournament uh pretty
much in its entirety uh through through
the Through The Eyes of vasel evanchook
and we've covered all of the games that
he won you can see that he finished half
a point ahead of garikasparov uh
Kasparov had 9 out of 13. only while one
lost uh even two in this tournament and
vasel finished with nine nine and a half
out of 13. so uh and an incredible feat
in itself but the games that he played
are so good you guys if you haven't seen
them really do check them out um uh the
game against kasparo for example one of
his best games one of uh kasparov's most
crushing defeats that he ever had if you
haven't seen it uh there will be a link
in the description below uh with all the
six games that I've covered from this
tournament basically it's a playlist
from the Linares Tournament of 1991. so
do check it out
um yeah especially if you're in my uh
fan you you will enjoy this now let's
check out the game and also there is a
very very important announcement at the
end of this video uh so stay tuned stay
tuned for that as well so uh in in this
game I've also had the white pieces and
he opened uh with E4 now this is a game
from round 10 I believe and or maybe
around nine but in the previous uh game
he he defeated anandine in in great
style so lubovic has to be very very
careful uh Manchu is having a perfect
tournament but he would very much like
to ruin it for him so we have C5 uh
sorry not D5 C5 which goes for the
Sicilian Defense we have Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Pawn the D4 the
open Cillian now also one thing I wanted
to address is the ratings um 26.95 for
vassel and 25.94
back then you the the ratings list lists
were released twice a year I think in
January and in June uh so uh as this
tournament was played in March uh I'm
pretty sure that uh the the the June uh
rating list was the one to consider so
that's why I put the one that uh 26.95
in even though uh the one from uh June
uh sorry this one is from January the
one from June uh Evancho is 27 35 or
something so uh in case anyone was
wondering about that yeah but okay C
captures on the four Knight captures and
queen the C7 dubovich goes for the floor
variation and now Knight to C3 and
Knight the B5 are the main moves here
but here vasel plays Bishop D2 a rare
move now but back then it was maybe even
a novelty so upon the E6 with quantity
for now grabbing it hold of the D5
square and the Knight captures on D4 and
it is now already as of move 6 that is
position has never been reached again so
okay Queen captures on D4 we have
Knights the E7 and now Bishop to E3 just
nicely continuing development Knight the
C6 uh attacking the queen queen goes
back and now Bishop to B4 so you will
meet a nicely developing his pieces with
Tempo Knights the C3 and queen to E5
probably beating F4 so he can go Queen
to A5 uh it's hard to say if if it's um
if it's a good plan but probably
something that he had prepared as he was
a fan of the of this uh variation with
the queen and C7 so here we have castles
castles and now Rook a to C1 by vasel
Pawn to B6 and Rook after D1 just
putting pieces on optimal squares Bishop
to C5 now putting pressure on the bishop
and you know that A3 B4 is coming so you
might as well move the bishop right away
and it's still not a bad plane you can
still play play A3 B4 as you probably
always should but here we have bishop
captress and C5 and now B captures and
C5 and here was says that he is not
worried about not being able to play B4
and that he has other plans so here we
have Queen to D6 he offers a queen trade
and will try to take advantage of of a
Black's Central pawns maybe not being
optimally placed we have F6 and now
Ponte F4 forcing the queen trade Queen
captures on D6 with Rook captures and D6
and now King to F7
uh bringing the king into into the game
and now Rook back the D2 the the reason
why uh he goes back is that if you
double up for example Knight the D4 is
very annoying Now The Rook is stuck on
D6 the king can attack it so maybe not
the the greatest of options so Rook the
D2 was played later on you can double up
on the D file uh King to E7 and now
Bishop to D1 Shifting the bishop over to
this diagonal we have Pawn to G5 and now
Pawn to F5 we have Pawn to D6 and now
Bishop to A4 stop putting pressure on
the Knight Knight the E5 now putting
pressure on the C4 pawn and pawn to B3
so this kind of locks your light score
Bishop uh on the queen side but that's
where where Russell wanted it to be uh
either way so here we have Pawn to A6 uh
and now okay stopping Knight to B5 and
now Rook C the D1 doubling up preparing
the capture that D6 Pawn we have rooked
the d8 and now Rook the F1 uh you need
to defend your your F1 because then just
capture actress and Bishop capture so
first he tried going after the D6 Pawn
but now the lubemate defended it now he
shifts the attention to defending the F5
Pawn so Bishop to B7 now putting
pressure on e4 and just The Rook F to D1
you no longer have to worry about your
F5 pawn and probably as this was uh
already uh 10th round uh he probably was
kind of even offering a draw here maybe
if Bishop to C8 he would just repeat
Rook F2 Bishop to B7 uh but which wants
to play he plays Rook a to B8 and okay
this means no no draw just yet Rook to
F1 and now Pawn to H5 lubo mirror
continues pushing with Pawn to H3 and
pawn to H4 we have rooked the EQ now uh
here uh he wants to get the knight uh to
a better Square so he has to First
Defender the pawn on e4 uh but also uh
if you guys are thinking about F
captures and E6 it is possible for
example King captures and Rook dtf2 now
attacks the F6 Pawn Rook f8 and now
let's say Rook F5 is sort of active for
white but there's no clear way of how to
how to actually continue playing this so
that's why it probably Rook the two by
Russell uh Rook to G8 and now we have
Knights the D1 re-maneuvering the Knight
we have pawned the G4 now getting ready
to bust open the G file and here we have
Knight the F2 and this is where problems
uh start for uh vasel Evancho uh he
should have played age captures on G4
but even this is very very hard to play
look at this Rook captures on G4 F
captures an E6 game captures and now
Knight D3 you can attack The Rook Rook
captures an E4 you're we're gonna lose
that pawn either way Knight the D5 with
a very tricky move now if you capture
The Rook then look at this Rook captures
an F6 Checkmate but of course um
wouldn't do that he would have to
capture the Knight here and after C
captures King captures you would play
Rook captures King captures and you will
gobble up the pawn on F6 and you will
have the same game Bishop against the
Knight and um uh black would be up upon
so uh vastu would have to fight for for
a draw here very very uh hard because
that deep on the pass deep on is very
very dangerous so instead he played
Knight to F2 and now his problems really
start but only if lubemere finds the
correct idea and he doesn't he plays e
captures on F5 the best way to play was
Knight to F3 check
uh the problem of course is you you
can't capture back if you capture back G
captures on F3 you open up this diagonal
then you lose the Rook then you lose the
uh this diagonal so uh not to the
greatest so you're gonna have to play
King to H1 and now Knight to D4 and now
the point is after The Rook moves The
Rook is attacked The Rook D3 G captures
an H3 Rook captures an H3 and now Knight
captures on F5 and you're lost whatever
you play uh because if you capture the
Knight then just Bishop captures on G2
with check Forks everything the king and
the two Rooks it doesn't matter where
you go you're gonna lose one of the
Rooks so let's say King H1 Bishop
captures an F1 or if after this um uh
move of Knight captures and F5 you don't
capture the Knight what else can you
play there's really not all that much
you can do you can play Rook D1 or
something just move the move the Rook
because Knight to G3 check is also a
threat which will win the exchange so
you could play something like Rook D1
but then comes Knight to G3 checking to
G1 and Rook h shade and okay you have uh
yeah you have not lost the exchange or
anything but the other Rook is coming to
G8 the Knight is Forever on G3 the pawn
and H4 is very strong uh the bishop here
also a monster So you you're not gonna
survive this position so that's how it
should have continued for him uh for
luver Knight to F3 was incredibly strong
but he played e captures on F5 he
captures an F5 and now G captures an H3
he wanted to open up his uh light Square
Bishop Knight captures an H3 and now
Rook the G4 uh Rook to G3 also makes
sense he decided to go for Rook to G4
King to H dude now getting uh the King
off of the G file and now Rogue beat the
G8 putting immense pressure on that G2
Pawn Knights the F4 you have to defend
the pawn and here comes King to F7 King
the d8 was much stronger but in the end
we'll get a similar position so uh we
don't need to discuss King 38 so King to
F7 and now comes Rook the D2 now the
problem is here to hold this position
properly you have to play Knight to G6
B4 is also fine I know you guys are
looking at that but Knights the G6 is
the way to hold this point is that after
Knight captures F characters and The
Rook captures you can play Rook f2f2 uh
sorry Rook after F2 and you will have
your G2 Pawn defended nicely and um okay
you're down upon but you will be able to
hold this however in the game yeah after
King to F7 Russell played Rook to D2 and
now uh the problem is here vassal
offered a draw and Livermore accepted
the draw I don't know what the time on
the clocks were uh so it could be that
lubevich was in a very serious time
trouble but here they agreed to a draw
the problem uh for vasilis or rather it
would have been if the game continued is
that the boy which is completely winning
here but it's not easy to to spot why
obviously none of them spotted it or
maybe Russell spotted it so he offered
that quick draw it's hard to say but
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out the winning uh maneuver for
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Ponta
H3 it's a very very strong move that
really doesn't offer you uh all that
much to do now the Knight cannot move uh
as The Rook captures on G2 will be
deadly so the Knight needs to keep
guarding the G2 Square so G captures on
H3 has to be played G captures and H3
and now the move that obviously lubovic
missed is Rook to G1 incredible idea uh
point being that after root captures and
G1 there's Knight to F3 with check King
H1 and Rook captures and G1 with
Checkmate okay it's not a fourth
Checkmate after Rook to G1 you of course
don't have to capture but what what do
you play you can play Rook D to F2 you
could defend like this but now Rook
captures an F1 Rook captures and again
Knight to F3 check and this is now a
problem if you move the king and your
only square is the H1 Square Here Comes
Knight the D2 check and you're just
gonna use the Rook King H2 Knight
captures an F1 it even comes with
Checkmate as the bishop slices over this
way and the root covers the G1 Square so
what you would have to do is play Rook
captures on F3 grab that Knight give up
the The Exchange and try to hold the
same game you would be up a pawn but you
would be done the exchange objectively
this is completely winning for black so
this is what he missed and it's a very
very good for Evancho that he did
because this uh the final standings
would not be as they are he would be
maybe an eight and a half and the
kaspara would have won the tournament uh
but it was a very very complicated line
to spot you have to see H3 and then Rook
to G1 and then you you kind of win win
the position uh but yeah incredible
stuff and
um uh probably what happened is that uh
okay probably which was obviously very
happy with a draw against devanshu who
already defeated uh kaspar of carpool
and Anand uh but still If he if he
smelled something there he probably
would have looked for it uh probably it
was due to time travel or maybe he just
trusted vastly in his draw offer he
thought okay it's a drive muscle offers
a draw maybe it's a draw uh who am I to
to reject this very nice draw of her uh
but yeah like I said uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and if you
haven't do check out all of vasel's
games from this tournament they are
absolutely phenomenal will be the second
link in the description below and the
first link is in the description below
is something that I wanted to talk to
you guys about for the past year we have
been working on a chess school it's a
it's a kind of a different Concept in
improving your chest than there exists
today is sort of a completely unique
concept because we're not creating
content we're just curating all of the
content available in the world and the
creating action items from that content
so you apply for the app you uh say okay
I may be good at the end game I'm good
at the middle game I'm good at the
openings and then the the app will take
yes you the app will trust you and it
will offer you action items to improve
your game so if something that we've
been working on like I said for uh for
the past year and now it's currently
being tested in uh in it's sort of in
beta stage if you will and uh I would
very much like it if you guys uh tried
it out it's free uh it's free to try out
and
um uh if you see anything that you would
like to improve if you see anything that
you would like to add if you if you see
anything that you would like to remove
from the app there is a feedback option
that you got that you can use to send us
your your opinions uh so I'm gonna
create a detailed analysis and the
detailed explanation of the app but for
now if any of you are interested you can
download it will be the first link in
the description below apply test that
give us your your thoughts on the uh on
the on the app and uh well I'm gonna
like I said discuss it a bit more create
a very separate video for the app so
we're gonna to go in depth and into
every detail regarding the app then but
for now try it out let me know what you
think and you know I hope hope you guys
enjoy it uh so yeah that's the game and
the little bit of info about the
tournament and the the app we are
creating hope you enjoyed that I would
like to thank Kathleen Northrop Yoon
young Ned Riley BBC chess uh BB chess
and London system for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day